[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to spectator out loud
the podcast where every week we pick a
few of our writers in the magazine
to read their pieces out to you this
week we'll be joined by kate andrews
economics correspondent
who writes about why she's voting for
joe biden despite being a lifelong
republican
then we'll be joined by matthew paris
who gives the recommendation to go to
sweden while you still can
and at the very end rory sutherland
wonders whether or not he's cracked
covered testing first up kate andrews
for as long as i was old enough to think
about politics i've been a republican
when my dad told me age six that bill
clinton had beaten bob dole
i'm told i cried i don't remember this
but i do have vivid memories of running
around san andreas in my first year at
university
in a handmade mccain palin t-shirt with
no bama
sketched in sharpie on the back i
graduated into an internship on mitt
romney's campaign
and when i moved to london i became a
spokesman for republicans overseas
never in my wildest dreams would i have
imagined the first time i voted democrat
would be to put barack obama's vice
president in the oval office
yet i'm voting for joe biden and kamala
harris
i know their economic policies will make
america poorer especially as the economy
tries to recover from covet 19
the tax rises and the huge increase in
spending
the kind that senator biden used to be
wary of
and this is now the moderate wing of the
party biden's vp
pick is even further to the left
harris's approach to governing would be
even more top-down and interventionist
her politics and mine i'm a liberal in
the british sense of the word
are about as far apart as one can get
but what about the alternative
what about donald trump the nastiness
unkindness
the racism and misogyny the way he
always punches down rather than up
it's the antithesis not just of my
politics but of the america that i love
his supporters claim his remarks are
taken out of context by his opponents in
the media
that what he says is made to sound worse
than what he meant
but we've all watched enough clips to
know that the president needs
no embellishment the only way to pretend
he didn't propose a ban
on muslims coming to the united states
is to close your eyes and pretend you
didn't read it on his campaign website
the only way to claim he didn't mock a
reporter's physical disability
is to look away and pretend that it
never happened
after eight lackluster years under
president obama
i felt as if a shift was coming sure i
had my personal favorites in the lineup
of republican candidates
the ones with a libertarian streak but
at the start of election season you
would have struggled to find an expat
more excited to make the case abroad
for the gop candidate my enthusiasm fell
away
when trump called mexicans rapists this
was unforgivable
not that he has ever asked for
forgiveness the party of ronald reagan
didn't demonize migrants in this way
but trump did in the end a major shift
did come
but i didn't take part this isn't to say
i begrudge trump voters
the vitriol thrown at them often mirrors
how the president treats his critics
and his supporters are right to point to
his policy successes
trump's tax reforms have resulted in
companies big and small hiking wages and
dishing out bonuses for american workers
it's not a terrible surprise to us free
market lot but his combination of lower
taxes and light touch regulation
produced a booming economy before the
virus hit
last year saw a spectacular 6.8 percent
rise in household medium income
the highest increase since records began
his less
interventionist stance on the world
stage has saved countless lives abroad
the first step act has done more to
reform criminal justice
and help non-violent offenders
rehabilitate than any republican or
democrat policy in years
in this sense the president has been
good for america
and i've asked myself many times if i
can separate the man from his words
hold my nose and cast my vote for the
continuation of these policies
the answer is always no because what is
at stake is bigger than the economy
bigger than any piece of legislation
that could cross the president's desk
the social fabric of america is coming
undone and if it unravels much more
i fear it won't be possible to stitch it
back together
i've never felt further away from my
home country than i did this summer
sitting in my london flat during
lockdown watching on tv
as the divisions that had been stoked in
american society for years reached
breaking point trump thrives on
chaos and ego after the murder of george
floyd he quickly made the protests and
rides about him personally
as if he were the victim of police
brutality or as if setting fires to
shops and cars
was more of an attack on him than on the
americans watching their businesses and
possessions burn to the ground
trump hasn't been alone in fostering
instability
many factions of the democratic party
never accepted that he won the 2016
election fairly
and tried to use every tool they could
to overturn the result
but trump has encouraged everyone to
meet him at the basis level
lauren witzke a republican candidate for
the senate
shared just days ago her belief that
most third world migrants cannot
assimilate into civil societies
as if this were now a socially
acceptable way to speak about other
human beings in america
miss whitski is responsible for her own
words but the president has created an
atmosphere in which people feel
emboldened to share these beliefs
this is a culture that arises when a
nation's leader never embraces humility
compromise or anything remotely
resembling a statesmanlike demeanor
the first presidential debate reminded
me once again that trump has not
bothered to learn
any of these lessons the interrupting
yelling and spin were bad enough
but the dismissal of beau biden when the
former vice president
was paying tribute to his late son was
one of trump's most inhumane moments to
date
it's hard to imagine a person could
stoop much lower and yet i can't help
but think
given four more years trump wouldn't
hesitate to show us
in 2016 i broke with the republican
party for the first time and supported
the libertarian candidate
i vote in a solidly democratic state so
i had the luxury of casting a protest
vote
against a system that made americans
choose between two members of the new
york elite
the least popular presidential
candidates in history
both of whom acted as though becoming
president was their birthright rather
than the highest privilege
but this time i'm protesting by joining
the other side
there is a candidate in this race who
well far from perfect
has a history of reaching across the
aisle he has based his campaign on
reuniting the nation and perhaps
most importantly in this election cycle
has reminded
us that it's okay to apologize now and
again
america does not have a monarchy the
president is our head of state and our
moral compass
trump has proven time and time again
that he is unfit for these roles
i like to believe a republican leader is
waiting around the corner to restore the
values and principles
that once made the party great until
then
i'm happy for the oval office to be
filled by someone who has a different
vision for america than i have but who
loves the country
and what it stands for nonetheless that
was kate
andrews and now matthew paris an idea
gains ground
that we shouldn't go abroad anymore that
the very act of travelling without
urgent reason is somehow irresponsible i
don't subscribe to this
to me travel has always been such an
important and
productive part of life a source of
knowledge and happiness
so while i can travel i will
but quarantine is making it harder
my partner and i belong to what one
survey reports is the
18 of quarantined people who actually do
stay at home
much as i love our derbyshire home 14
days quarantined in one corner of the
peak district
is a serious deterrent from visiting
most of the rest of the world
but not from visiting sweden yet
as i write their covered case rate is
about a quarter of britain's
and our requirement to quarantine does
not apply to people arriving from
stockholm
nor do the swedes make british visitors
quarantine
so off we went on a four-day trip to a
country
very close to these islands but which
millions of us hardly know
true i once spent a new year in a log
cabin in the woods in central sweden
fun but we saw only snow and trees
otherwise
my last visit was half a century ago
since then i felt i knew sweden only by
reputation
that reputation proved so very wide of
the mark
call me ignorant and i was but my
childish idea of the country
was of a sort of frontier land a few
modest conurbations around sweden's
baltic and north sea coast
and then vast swathes of coniferous
nothingness
punctuated by the occasional clapboard
barn and some sweet little lutheran
churches
stretching up towards the north pole
culturally i'd
again ignorantly suppose that apart from
strindberg
a playwright whose work i find
impenetrable and of course abba
well what else was there beyond europe's
most successful purveyor
of flat pack furniture politically
i'd thought of sweden as slightly
sanctimonious
much into good work among the
non-aligned and developing countries and
ducking the big issues domestically
i'd supposed this was the ultimate
cradle to grave welfare state
dispiritingly level unmaterialistic
conformist distrustful of wealth or
display
and characterized by a faint antiseptic
odor of self-righteousness
well four days into stockholm and
gothenburg
and the journey between them put me
right that's plainly
far too short a time to forge a rounded
impression of a great nation
and scantifile readers will be laughing
at me already
laughing at how little i know even now
but how much less did i know before i
went
if a nation can be said to have dna
sweden's dna is of a boss nation
pennants in their national colors of
blue and yellow fly from flagpoles on
people's lawns
like us they've lost an empire in their
case a european one
and like us they do feel special
everything from their amazing galleries
and museums
to their tremendous warship the vassa
sunk in 1628
and now raised preserved and displayed
in a vast and beautiful museum
the size of two aircraft hangars six
floors high
everything from their very slightly
aloof courtesy
to their ability to laugh at themselves
and at each other
breathes self-assurance
stockholm is magnificent reminding me in
some ways of edinburgh
not charming not quaint and not in the
feminine sense
beautiful perhaps the capital has a
certain lack of what one might call
grace but it's handsome intelligent
solid monumental conscious of its
architectural personality
and resolved to cherish it wide streets
lovely parks strict limits on the
heights of buildings
and everywhere the little touches
flourishes
trademarks of a city that knows all
about display
but has a sharper version to vulgarity
from the skinny black jeans to the black
leather accessories to the rock walls
and
soaring artwork of the underground
stations i can
think of no national culture with so
strong a sense of style
and where had all the fat people gone
most people of my age
work out go to gyms a waiter told me
and the older people they walk cycle
exercise at home
i did finally spot three obese people
at a table near us at one of the city's
hundreds of pavement cafes
they were english we missed by
two days the opening of a new opera by
rufus wainwright
in the city's grand opera house on one
day
we were impulse buying an ultra smart
pale green coffee percolator
wandering the six floors of what must
surely be europe's most elegant and
high-end department store
nk in stockholm so much less crass than
harrods
is on some kind of a cusp between the
old
pre john lewis peter jones in chelsea
the old
liberty of oxford street and wanna
makers
in philadelphia a day later
we were walking a nature trail beneath
oak birch and pine trees
where the earth bleeds black on the
granite strewn strusso island of
gothenburg
and after that shrimps and roast smoked
salmon
outside a little restaurant beneath the
chestnut trees
then back by ferry to gothenburg after
nipping into a public loo
that you paid by credit card to enter
sweden it sometimes felt is what in the
1950s
the world of the future was going to be
like but it never happened
except in sweden
and i discovered nordic art at the
gothenburg museum of art and at the
theosca gallery in the woods outside
stockholm
where swedish ladies who lunch sip dry
white wine
to a backdrop of a postcards of eugene
janssen's paintings of naked men diving
we encountered mainstreams of european
painting
from the 1500s through rembrandt and van
dyke
to the nordic expressionists of the
early 20th century
who knew that edvard monk painted not
only nietzsche
but his ghastly nazi anti-semitic sister
elizabeth ii to the british mind
the idea of sweden seems to hover on the
european fringe
spend even a few days in its powerful
gravity field
and the country feels close to the
center of our continent
and its heritage hurry there while we
still
can that was matthew paris and now rory
sutherland
the covid problem lies as much in the
delayed action of the virus
as in the virus itself
since symptoms emerge only days after
infection
testing often comes too late to reveal
how transmission occurred
and often too late to prevent onward
transmission since many people may be
most contagious before symptoms even
appear
this delay makes the targeting of
restrictions far more complex
a bit like weather forecasting only in
reverse
for this reason what we may have to fear
most from bioterrorism
is not the pathogens that are most
deadly but those with a delayed action
now if kovind had immediate effects say
your hair instantly turned purple when
you were infected
we might have cracked the problem by now
yet we still don't know
say whether the size of the initial dose
affects the severity of the disease
that would affect the case for masks for
instance
we also don't know what causes
super-spreading events
is it the location or the person are
some people largely unsusceptible
one serious theory suggests the internal
shape of your nose
may have a bearing on the outcome it all
falls within that area of human
knowledge
where science falls short you neither
have quite enough information
nor can you ethically perform
experiments to fill the gaps in your
knowledge
this was not quite so difficult in 1721
charles maitland a scottish surgeon
received a royal license to conduct an
experimental
inoculation or variolation on six
subjects
who are deliberately exposed to a small
dose of smallpox
all were inmates of newgate prison and
were granted a full pardon
in the event that they survived happily
all six did
later one was deliberately exposed to
smallpox
and it turned out he was immune so it
occurred to me there must be many
prisoners today who'd welcome a similar
offer
and whose release would pose no risk to
anyone
bernie madoff perhaps all those men
behind that vault raid in hatton garden
none of these people was violent and the
vols customers were probably every bit
as dodgy as the people who broke in
the main reason for their long sentences
is simply to deter
others from similar acts now it might be
that living as i do in west kent i have
excessive sympathy
for people who perform large-scale
heists given how much they contribute to
our local economy
nonetheless i wondered if you could
offer younger such inmates
the same deal that was available in 1721
so in a step rare in british journalism
i decided to share my suggestion with
someone who knows what they're talking
about
in this case near ayal professor of
bioethics at
rutgers in new jersey and what he told
me was fascinating
such trials where you deliberately
expose people to infection at various
levels
are known as challenge trials many
scientists believe that it may be
impossible to test the full efficacy and
safety of any potential vaccine
without them and there's also a growing
scientific consensus
that any such vaccine trials will
accelerate the development of
coronavirus vaccines
potentially saving hundreds of thousands
of lives
moreover to be fully robust such trials
often require a control group
people exposed to the virus who've been
given a placebo
not the rail trial vaccine this action
presumably reveals what causes
protection in those successfully
vaccinated
e.g it's only by performing challenge
trials of this kind
that you can reliably see the
correlations that reveal
which antibody successfully vaccinated
people have developed that others
haven't
an organization called onedaysoona.org
already has about forty thousand
volunteers around the world
who are happy to take this risk in
reality
only a hundred or so would be needed for
a useful trial though
but there are still two questions if the
case for such trials is compelling
might it not have made sense to have
performed just a few of these trials
a few months earlier in the pandemic to
better investigate in individuals the
early stage of infection
about we still know far too little
and another question do we really
believe that a few countries haven't
secretly done this already
that was rory sutherland thanks for
listening and join us again next week
[Music]
you